- It all comes down to this. Three, two, one.
- Ah!
- Guess what time it is? "Underrated,"
the only show that allows
professional athletes
to improve their ratings
in their favorite video games, and today,
Michael Porter Jr.
We're gonna go
to our 2K gamer Davisss to see how
he stacks up in the game.
- We been knew Michael Porter Jr.
could shoot, all right?
But the finishing is what's
severely underrated. In the last season,
I really think he's shown
that he can finish well at the paint.
We need to see that reflected in 2K.
The small forward is an extremely versatile position.
Not only do you need to be able to shoot,
but you need to be able to finish on people, dunk on 'em.
- I hear that you believe you deserve
a badge for contact finishing.
- Yeah.
You're driving to the lane,
taking the bump and finishing the basket.
- Yeah.
- And you don't have one.
- Right. Contact finishing,
that is definitely something
I want to get up in my 2K rating.
- And if you had an issue
with not having badges or ratings,
who would you normally hit up, like who?
- You gotta hit up Ronnie.
- Well, guess what? Ronnie!
Ah! Ronnie is in the building.
- Yessir.
- OK, finishing through contact.
- Yep.
Can we talk about how important a badge is
to a player in the game?
- Yeah, we had separated contact
finisher for dunking and contact finisher for layups.
- Mmm.
- And we felt like that was duplicative.
So now we have it for one.
That's what we're playing here for. That's
what we're here for.
We're gonna find out
whether you can contact finish.
- I need you to know this is a big deal.
- Yeah, you got the spotlight on you
and you can prove it out.
I wanna see it.
- I appreciate you letting me come through.
- Of course, brother.
- Now, if you don't do well,
there is the risk that you go down.
- In my rating? Oh, that's not gonna happen.
- OK. You're confident.
- We're goin' up. Today.
- Here's how this is gonna work:
We got Ronnie on the block.
First off, he's got these paddles.
There's gonna be five drives
that you have to do.
You've gotta make at least four,
but it's gonna get harder every time.
- OK.
- Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- K.
- Be gentle.
- Three, two, one, go.
- Hey!
- Lotta contact.
- Are you all right?
- Yeah.
- Lotta contact. That was an and-1.
- I caught him in the face.
We're advancing past the sticks.
Bring in the balls.
Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- Three, two, one.
- Hey!
- Oh, oh, oh!
- Contact finishing.
- If one was good, two is better.
Let's bring 'em both out. Three, two, one.
- Hey!
- I don't think there's anything gonna stop you.
- He got an animal in him.
I mean, he is ferocious.
- He's three for three.
He's going for four for four.
MPJ. In three, two, one, go.
- Hey!
- He missed?
- What happened?
- You know what? I went
with the one hand. Around the rim.
You gotta go with two. Made a mistake.
- He adapts. He learns. He adjusts.
It all comes down to this.
Michael Porter Jr.
Three for four. Has to go four
for five to get the bronze badge.
We now have three balls.
Three, two, one.
- Hey, hey, hey!
- Oh, no! No!
That was right there.
- It was in.
It was in.
- It was right there. The balls were bouncing.
- It was right there, man.
- You seem impressed, though.
- Yeah, I was impressed.
I mean, he got, he got where
he needed to go.
That's all that matters.
- With that being said,
- Yes.
- are you willing to throw a badge?
He didn't did the 80 percent,
but I feel like you're impressed.
So I feel very confident that he will get,
that he will get that badge.
I think he deserves it for sure.
- Your level of excitement and joy,
where are we at right now?
- Very excited. You know, sometimes you get hacked.
Sometimes you're not gonna finish every layup.
You might go to the free-throw line.
- Yeah.
- I'm sure, like, I got fouled on that last play.
- That's probably true.
- So now we know Michael Porter Jr.
can finish in the paint.
But now I want to see him
in 2K being able to, you know,
hit 'em with a jab step, get to the paint
and shoot up a nice little floater.
Tear Dropper is the badge we're gonna
need to see. That is the badge that,
if someone's in the paint, and you just want to shoot
a little floater over top,
easy buckets right there.
- I heard you saying earlier
that nobody has a better teardrop than you.
- No doubt, cuz it's the in-between
game, you know? Sometimes
you come off a pick-and-roll or whatever.
There's a lot of big guys now.
- Yeah.
You might want to shoot the
in-between little floater, get an easy two.
- It's gonna be hard again.
You gotta hit a floater over
each of our obstacles.
Miss three floaters,
you don't get the tear drop badge.
Let's see if he can do it.
All right. Easy one up first.
Some small trees. In three, two,
one, go.
- Oh, no.
- K, that's a strike.
That's a strike.
- We get three of them.
- OK, we got three of them.
- A little more speed.
- Oh, yeah.
OK, OK, OK. All right.
- It would've been tough to get out of there
if he had missed both of those.
- All right.
We are gonna now upgrade it from the trees
to the T. rex.
Dinosaur has entered the building.
Is there a defender in the NBA
that has this profile, remind you of?
- You know what, I think this reminds me
more like Tacko Fall.
Probably about 7'5", 7'6".
- He's got that height. All right.
So you got one strike.
Let's get this done on the first try.
- Let's do it.
- Three, two, one, go.
- Ooh, looked nice. Looked good. Looked nice.
- And it was a swish.
- Looked real nice.
- You know what? When I got up to the T. rex,
I couldn't even see my target.
So I had to jump up a little bit, float it up there.
- Well, this one's gonna be hard.
One strike. Two baskets.
And it all comes down to this.
- Oh!
- Oh Snap.
- All the way up there?
- This is a 14-foot defender.
- OK.
- You seem see that?
He touched the bottom of his shoes?
- Yeah, oh.
- That's when you know it's serious.
- It's real now.
- For an NBA 2K badge. Three, two, one.
- The height. Ahh.
- Ooh.
- He is on line.
- Yep. It looked good.
- I play good under pressure.
My last strike?
- This is it.
- Let's get it.
- For a badge, Michael Porter Jr.
- All comes down to this.
- Three, two, one.
- Wooh!
- Yes. Buckets. Give that man a badge.
- Impressive. All right.
- With one strike to spare.
Congratulations. How did that feel?
- That was great. Give me my badge.
- All right. Just take me through what
that felt like.
- It felt more realistic than I thought.
You know, I got up here,
saw the taller defender.
A lot of times, guys are jumping so high
you gotta get it up.
So that's what I did and it dropped.
- Do we get two badges today?
- I feel pretty good about it.
You know, I don't
think we can deny him
any of those badges, as much as I want to.
And now is my favorite
question I get to ask
Ronnie 2K, is Michael Porter Jr.
underrated?
I guess so. I mean, we missed two badges.
- Yes. How does it feel to be
the proud owner of two new badges in NBA 2K?
- It feels good, man. I'm gonna start playing
my player more cuz I'mma stop
smoking layups, smoking floaters.
- Michael Porter Jr. Officially underrated.
I'm proud of you.
- Yes, sir.